here's what would happen if you made it  with a neanderthal if neanderthals and  yeah that's how you pronounce it if they  were still around today and one was your  partner you'd want to dine in more often  especially when you consider that a  neanderthal needs to eat 700 more  calories than a human every day plus  their table manners might be a bit messy  neanderthals live in small communities  and inbreeding was a common practice so  your potential in-laws would all be in  fierce competition for your partner's  affection neanderthals were known for  their broad noses and protruding brows  and while your kids might not inherit  those features they could have massive  molars a large bone behind their ear or  frontal face flattening your children  could suffer from blood clots and be at  risk for catching communicable diseases  like covet 19 also human females mating  with neanderthal males would be less  likely to have fertile children so